love simon was one of my favorite things
that i've been on
i think the series is very different if
they ask me to come back i'm sure i
would
consider it but i think i think it's a
different view with victor
that i'm not in at the moment no caitlin
was cute
airy hardly a reason to pop like a zit
what happened
caitlyn exploded what like a good bomb
no like
a balloon what catherine you have
such an incredible knack for finding
women who are so
dynamic on screen mara is just such an
amazing kick-ass female that girls
everywhere are going to want to embody
what was it about this role that made it
so that you're like i need to be a part
of this movie
a lot if not all the credit goes to
brian duffield and aaron who originally
wrote the book
and kind of came up with not only these
characters like
mara and dylan but also this whole
premise which
feels like it hits quite differently now
to when we made it a couple of years ago
it's zany it's kind of satirical again
and it has a very specific dialogue but
it just felt different and cool
it felt very cool and i feel like you
guys must have broken some kind of
record for the most amount of blood
on the set of a movie
it happened again a lot what was the
biggest challenge when you guys were
filming and you were
completely covered in blood while you
guys were on set i think i had it pretty
good actually i
remember hearing a story about catherine
doing a particularly
emotional scene and the subzero kind of
temperatures
of vancouver in the winter i definitely
didn't have to do anything like that
i think after like a week of having fake
blood on you it all just kind of
blurs together a little bit so so it
wasn't too bad at all
catherine it was so interesting to see
that you were such a blonde in this
movie
because it made the blood in your hair
just such an eerie twist
was that a conscious choice in part of
her character
we kind of just talked about how she
would look and then that
fact was brought up sort of in in
conversation
but it felt cool to kind of create this
character you know she's sort of a
non-blonde like
we had the wig made so that it looks
like she's she's dyed her hair and i
quite like that element because she
feels to me like someone who's restless
and wants to change
as we all do we change when we feel like
something isn't sitting quite right or
maybe we just want something fresh
but yeah it it definitely kind of made
the blood pop
a lot more i have a moment for you where
i knew i liked you
you liked me i'm just so glad i didn't
explode all over you
i think that fans are gonna fall head
over heels from mara and dylan's
relationship how did you guys find that
off-screen connection
to make it so that you had such great
on-screen chemistry i think
there's a good amount of it where we
just got really lucky and fortunately
before i got cast i got to meet with
katherine and we got to just kind of
talk about
the script and the characters and i
think we also really wanted it to be
as though they had a connection that of
course was romantic but also one that
was
really great friends too and they just
love to laugh and spend time together
and
i knew too catherine's just so talented
and she's really reading this story so i
just kind of had to
get out of the way as much as possible
it's absolutely true i remember early
days the search for dylan there was this
kind of want we wanted someone who felt
like you know was able to kind of
embody this this character on screen but
then also have that
sensitivity uh but also have that inner
strength that maura would gravitate
towards and then
charlie walked through the door and was
able to deliver this beautiful
and very heartfelt performance where you
fall in love with him on screen
and i think it was really beautiful to
be able to play that and
and to have mara and dylan together on
screen and that dynamic of the chaos and
the fire with
with dylan who is this complete rock um
for her love victor recently exploded
earlier this year catherine so many fans
are dying to know if we will see leah
appear on the series
you know i love simon is and was still
one of
my favorite things that i've been on i
think the series is very different
if they asked me to come back i'm sure i
would consider it but i think i think
it's a different
a different view with victor that i'm
not i'm not in at the moment